this is Elon talking with the Babylon B
guys about how NPR remember how NPR had
a Twitter fit because he labeled them
state-sponsored media and I'm pretty
sure they're not even on Twitter anymore
because of that even though they are
state-sponsored media and it used to be
on their website take a look
as you've seen we've open sourced the
algorithm uh and made at this point I
think well over 100 changes but how will
we stay informed if NPR isn't there
anymore
you know at any given point I'm not sure
if NPR is there or not I wasn't aware
that they were there until
they said they were not going to do that
I mean we're trying to apply the rules
consistently
at Twitter so that you know the NPR
thing is like well
um if we're gonna call some media State
Affiliated we'll there's plenty of
uh meet organizations in the in the US
that are or in the west that are State
Affiliated
um so then we should apply the label
equally
um
and then uh they're very upset about
that
um and so that there will stay
Affiliated implies that the state has
editorial authority of an influence over
the content and like
so you're saying you don't have that
right how software are you um
you know it was on their website well
yeah I mean they they well NPR are
literally on their own exactly on their
own website said I've ever you know
Government funding is essential to their
operation right and so we even changed
it from uh State Affiliated to state
funded
so that's just literally a statement of
fact right I mean we could actually just
lift the same text from their website
and put it at the label
and but they're still there and they're
unhappy with that yeah they're unhappy
with that the reason I really wanted to
show you this clip I get it none of you
love NPR and you don't care where their
NPR is on Twitter anymore and yes it was
a statement of facts saying you are
state funded media it used to literally
be on
nprs.org website that they were state
funded uh but the reason I really wanted
to show you that was because you know we
we deal with all this like woke nonsense
through these corporations and I show
you these clips of the Target CEO or the
Chick-fil-A CEO or the Bud Light
marketing executive all bowing to
wokeness no one's saying what they
really believe all like they're reading
a script you know we showed you even the
the Toronto Blue Jays picture yesterday
you know with his with his really
horrible apology struggle Mouse style
struggle section session where he's just
apologizing for having liked a Instagram
post about a boycott of Target the point
is that so few people are actually
willing to tell the truth or certainly
they're not willing to tell the truth
any sort of nuanced way with a little
bit of humor and everything else and
that's what you know having been to
Twitter a couple times and spent some
time with Elon like the guy is just
trying to do the right thing it's it's
just become so like patently obvious to
me and I think that's important
[Music]
foreign